ciel bleu thiébou diène poulet yassa
boubou non vous n'êtes pas à dakar mais
dans la grande banlieue madrilène
aujourd'hui ils sont 3000 sénégalais
venues pour la cérémonie du grand magal
traduisez le grand hommage la plus
importante fête musulmane à la sauce
sénégalaise
de retrouvailles et de rencontres le
joueur sait que compte tenu des
activités des diverses
ainsi mamadou à 40 ans il est éducateur
à madrid
cet après midi il est venu retrouver ses
amis et se ressourcer le grand magal
c'est avant tout un moment pieux en sous
sol on rend grâce au prophète mahomet et
au marabout cheikh ahmadou bamba qui
sait l'impact avec dieu il y à 116 ans
afin de réhabiliter l'islam au sénégal
[Musique]
80 % des sénégalais sont musulmans au
pays dans la ville sainte de touba le
grand magal rassemble près de 3 millions
de personnes ici à madrid durant 24
heures les fidèles entonneront leurs
innombrables chants sacrés et coulera à
flot le café touba la boisson officielle
du grand magal parmi les participants
quelques femmes
beaucoup d'hommes et aucune ride sur les
visages à l'image de leur pays les
sénégalais de madrid sont jeunes à dakar
la moitié de la population a moins de 30
ans mais le taux de chômage atteint 49%
la meilleure des raisons de quitter
l'afrique
le lendemain matin on retrouve mamadou
notre éducateur sa casquette et son
sourire ne le quitte jamais quand il va
au travail son bureau c'est cette maison
de proche banlieue
ici vivent huit jeunes sénégalais
débarqué seul en espagne jusqu'à leur
majorité
le gouvernement prend en charge leur
logement et leur offre une formation
professionnelle voilà on amène la bourre
pour toute la maison
[Musique]
mamadou c'est le grand frère chargé de
leur insertion dans la société espagnole
les yeux rivés sur son ordi capuche
vissée sur la tête
mustapha à 17 ans il en avait 13 quand
il a traversé la méditerranée
ses parents ont déboursé 700 euros une
année de salaire au sénégal pour payer
les passeurs beaucoup de ceux qui ont
tenté la traversée n'ont jamais atteint
les côtes espagnoles au sénégal
l'économie considéré un temps comme la
plus prometteuse d'afrique de l'ouest
n'a jamais décollé la pauvreté génère
toujours plus de candidats au départ par
centaines ils embarquent dans des
bateaux de fortune les pataras
destination l'europe
en 2006 ils étaient près de 40000
attentes et le périple
dizaine sont morts noyés depuis l'état
espagnol contrôler fermement son espace
maritime
en 2010 ils n'étaient plus que 3500
avoir atteint la péninsule ibérique par
la mer cette traversée
les jeunes protégés de mamadou l'ont
tous fait c'était le cld de talât qui
devaient embarquer mais tétanisés par la
peur il a cédé sa place au cadet de la
famille le voyage a duré six jours
[Musique]
quant à nous le cnda le canada d'abord
l'association pour laquelle travaillent
mamadou a accueilli plus de 80 jeunes de
moins de 18 ans devenu majeur
ils ont obtenu des papiers rendu visite
à leur famille au sénégal et tente de
trouver du travail en espagne moins
fortunés en revanche sont les sénégalais
arrivé sur le sol espagnol
après leur majorité à tiers d'entre 30
milles environ seraient clandestins dans
le quartier lava pièce le barbès
madrilène les sans papiers sont traqués
par la police
c'est ici le camp de base des sénégalais
de la capitale ici que mamadou enfile
son autre casquette de médiateur
bénévoles il en connaît toutes les
ruelles et tout le monde le connaît
ea mobile une solidarité d'autant plus
importante qu'avec la crise le regard
des espagnols sur ces étranges échanges
selon une étude récente 77 % jugent le
nombre d'immigrés en espagne excessif
ils n'étaient que 28 % en 1996 des cinq
est vraiment tu n'es pas c'est quoi en
2005 l'espagne a régularisé 600000
sans-papiers six ans et une récession
plus tard le pays se ravise
aujourd'hui l'état distribue des aides
au retour pourtant parmi tous les
sénégalais que nous avons rencontrés
dans le quartier lava pièce aucun
envisage dans l'immédiat un retour au
pays
en dépit de cette tendance au repli sur
soi pour certains l'espagne demeure une
société accueillante
madrid la nuit été comme hiver les rues
débordent de vie basse artiste peintre
sénégalais s'y sent comme chez lui salut
ça va où tu vas comme ça bah ça
longtemps baroud et équateur belgique
france c'est finalement à madrid qu'il a
choisi de poser ses valises
la première chose que j'ai aimé faire
ici c'est prendre le bus et observer les
gens sous ces jeunes tous ces vieux qui
discutent ensemble c'est pour ça que je
dis que l'espagne ressemble beaucoup au
sénégal les gens sont tous dans la rue
il ya de la vie si vous regardez autour
de vous il ya toujours énormément de
monde dehors ce qui attire basse
également c'est le foisonnement culturel
madrilène ses toiles il les exposer les
vents dans les bars du centre ville ce
sont les premières toiles que j'ai faite
en arrivant en espagne basse se définit
comme un artiste inclassable
ses peintures sont abstraites il se
plaît à déjouer les idées reçues ici les
gens ont tendance à penser que je
devrais faire des trucs typiquement
africain ils me disent tu peux peindre
une case part si tu peux prendre en
éléphant par là et moi je n'ai jamais
connu ce mode de vie et ses modèles
les clichés aussi ont la vie dure au
sénégal lors demain midi bas se
retrouvent mamadou au quartier lava
pièce dans un resto africain au menu
poulet yassa et débats sans concession
sur ces mirages qui trompe les
sénégalais les sénégalais arrivent ici
avec de fausses idées ils ne connaissent
rien à la réalité espagnole et
européenne
ils ont de mauvaises informations il
faut qu'ils sachent qu'ici ce n'est pas
le paradis c'est aussi la faute de nos
frères qui vivent en france ou aux états
unis
quand ils sont en visite au sénégal il
rentre avec 50 valises pleines à craquer
les jeunes bave devant et ça ça me fait
pleurer tout ça c'est de la merde les
pieds en europe la tête en afrique
voilà le défi lancé à cette génération
d'exilés se faire une place au soleil
d'espagne financer les vieux jours d ieu
restés au pays
sans renier sa culture d'origine
[Musique]